[Aplausos]
[Música]
imagínense
que les plantan un cadáver en medio del
primer cuadro de la ciudad y les hacen
pensar que esa persona
murió a causa del hobby 19
o que en las redes sociales se viralizó
la noticia de que fue un gobierno allá
muy lejos el responsable de haber creado
el coronavirus dentro de un laboratorio
o que por la aplicación de whatsapp esta
aplicación que muchos de nosotros
estamos se compartan a audios de
personas que supuestamente están
enfermas de del virus y que están
pidiendo a gritos que les ayuden porque
no tienen una atención médica
esto está pasando sin duda y sin duda
vivimos en un mundo bien extraño esto
por la sensación de irrealidad por la
que estamos pasando
debido a la pandemia se estima que el 86
por ciento de todos nosotros hemos
cambiado nuestros patrones de compra
pero principalmente de comunicación
si bien esta pandemia ha desatado lo que
ya han denominado como el plan
experience o las compras de pánico
debido al miedo a la realidad como ya
dije que estamos pasando también ha
desatado lo que han denominado el planet
communication que es la viralización de
aquellas noticias que nos hacen daño que
son falsas los pequeños como se le
conoce en inglés o como le vamos a
llamar la post verdad
como periodista siempre me he hecho esta
pregunta y ahora se las voy a hacer como
ciudadanos del mundo
creen que tenemos o no la
responsabilidad moral
y ética de parar la desinformación
qué piensan
yo pienso que sí especialmente ante una
sociedad irracional que comparte que
obtiene la sal la información de las
redes sociales y quedamos ya que estás
esa información pues simplemente es es
falsa
miren el problema es que las compañías
los gigantes de la tecnología como
facebook por ejemplo o como google ellos
no tienen como su norte operativo la
búsqueda de la verdad
ellos no m árbol a en el periodismo por
ejemplo que es una de mis pasiones en su
mejor versión que es precisamente esta
la búsqueda de la verdad ellos tienen
suficiente con maximizar su tráfico en
sus redes sociales y al mismo tiempo
maximizar sus ganancias económicas todo
a través de nuestro contenido
serían las noticias falsas pues no
explican el resultado de una elección
por ejemplo
de nuestra dieta informativa tiene mucho
que ver en este problema estas compañías
de las que les había platicado este se
ven como una avenida de información sin
tinas editoriales cuando en realidad
sabemos que ellos son compañías de
editoriales que regulan nuestro
contenido válgame pueden borrar el
perfil de cada uno de nosotros en un en
un segundo sin darnos cuenta por
cualquier presa
las noticias falsas son aquellas
afirmaciones
que apelan a nuestros sentimientos a
nuestras creencias dejando a un lado
los hechos objetivos la post verdad creo
yo se ha propagado exponencialmente
tanto como el hobby 19 nosotros como
ciudadanos tenemos la obligación tenemos
el derecho de obtener información veraz
no creen
pero esta epidemia informativa como ya
la están llamando es tan contagiosa como
la propia enfermedad les doy un ejemplo
el director de la organización mundial
de la salud la ong se ha dicho que si
bien si estamos luchando contra contra
la pandemia y contra el colonialismo
coronavirus perdón pero también estamos
luchando contra las noticias falsas pero
principalmente estamos luchando contra
aquellos los teóricos de la
desinformación que de alguna manera u
otra están socavando la respuesta eficaz
al brote sanitario y es que todo esto
corremos el grave daño de que las
noticias falsas afecten nuestra salud y
la salud de los más queridos de nosotros
y lo estamos viendo ya en la
en el hecho de que muchas personas pues
no quieren vacunarse
porque muchos dicen les van a implantar
un chip para rastrearlos cuando ya no se
están rastreando con nuestros propios
teléfonos inteligentes
hablando con compañeros periodistas a
uno de ellos es chris papá del
presidente del portal de internet el
paso del autobús él me dice que con algo
tan contagioso y tan peligroso pero
principalmente tan intangible nosotros
como humanos pues tendríamos a culpar al
otro de lo que estamos de lo que está
sucediendo y creemos más de noticias
conspiradoras porque de esa forma nos
hace sentir un poquito más mejor
desgraciadamente ya muchas personas no
acuden a los medios tradicionales de
noticias para obtener la información
porque dicen que están molestos y miren
que como director de noticias de un
medio tradicional allá en los eeuu
me doy cuenta de esa molestia claro que
sí porque de la misma forma muchos de
los medios de comunicación en todo el
mundo son culpables de esa
desinformación y es que para que la post
verdad o una noticia falsa tenga éxito
está debe poder ser cierta imagínense
eso es toda una paradoja
dentro de este mundo dentro de la post
verdad existen tres mundos el mundo real
que hace alusión a una noticia oa un
hecho antes de ser interpretado el mundo
de referencia que es cuando tomamos ese
hecho esa noticia y le planteamos el
marco interpretativo y el mundo de lo
posible que ahí es donde está el
problema que es la combinación de esos
dos mundos ahí como mínimo la historia
la noticia el hecho como ya dije debe
parecer verdad fíjese esto es construido
con el afán de ser creído así con toda
la alevosía
[Música]
y la lengua
desgraciadamente
entonces que debemos hacer para
identificar la verdad las noticias
falsas bueno hay que desconfiar de los
encabezados grandes y en mayúsculas hay
que ver si algún sitio cuenta con la
sección de about o el acerca de ya que
los muchos sitios no que no son
confiables no cuentan con esa sección o
si la tienen está totalmente incompleta
hay que revisar las citas creo yo que
como periodista un poco más visual hay
que hacer una búsqueda inversa de
imágenes o fotografías dentro de un
artículo por ejemplo los promotores de
la post verdad muchas veces sacan de
contexto las imágenes
yo los invito a que
evitemos ser parte de este jueguito y se
los digo como periodista los invito a
que
evitemos
acarrearnos por nuestros sentimientos
económicos o políticos aunque es bien
difícil yo lo comprendo todos tenemos
convicciones pero ahí es donde entra
nuestra responsabilidad colectiva
les hago esta invitación
antes de compartir algo piensa
no hay que ser parte del juego como ya
dije de sembrar el pánico
ante la posteridad
los hechos
y para comunicar bien los hechos
hay que dejarse informar
[Aplausos]